to adapt to make fit for to change to
suit a new purpose and as in the case of
our five nominees a writer takes a book
a short film or even a TV series and
turns it into cinematic gold here are
the nominees for Best Adapted Screenplay
based on the novel up in the air by
Walter Kern adapted screenplay by Jason
Reitman and Sheldon Turner based on the
novel push by Sapphire adapted
screenplay precious by Jeffrey Fletcher
based on the character Malcolm Tucker
who originally appeared in the BBC TV
show the thick of it adapted screenplay
in the loop by Jesse Armstrong Simon
blackwell Armando Iannucci and Tony
Roche based on a memoir by Lynn Barber
adapted screenplay and education by Nick
Hornby based on the short film alive in
joburg by Neil Blomkamp
adapted screenplay district 9 by Neil
Blomkamp and Terri Tatchell
and the winner is Jeffrey Fletcher for
precious based on a novel by Sapphire
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Geoffrey Fletcher
don't know what to say this is for
everybody who works on a dream everyday
precious boys and girls everywhere all
the cast and crew
anyone who's kept believing in me my two
brothers supported me in every way my
role models my hero's buddy and Todd my
mother Betty angel of my world my father
Alphonse I spent so much time with us
and taught us everything oh sorry I'm
drawing a blank right now but I think
you everyone